Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
announces Democrats will move forward
with impeachment Democrats call lawyers
to jabber how much about they hate Trump
and the Democrats have some explaining
to do on surveillance of political
opponents I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
express and VPN your data is your
business protected at expressive VPN
comm slash banner okay so the big news
of the day is that Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi has now formally announced
that the Democrats will move forward
with impeachment now this was a foregone
conclusion obviously the minute that she
announced there would be an impeachment
inquiry we knew where that was going
because after all why would the
Democrats announce an impeachment
inquiry and then a month later but yeah
you know we inquired it turns out he was
fine turns out was great the only reason
that you overtly announced an
impeachment inquiry as opposed to just
pursuing that inquiry sort of quietly is
because you know where this is going the
brick was already on the accelerator and
Nancy Pelosi just confirmed that today
yesterday she had gone to her Democratic
House caucus and she'd asked them quote
are you ready and apparently the answer
was a resounding yes according to the
Associated Press today Nancy Pelosi came
out and she made an announcement she
said I am asking my Democratic
colleagues to bring forward articles of
impeachment a hilariously enough I
should note that the Democrats don't
even know what these articles of
impeachment are going to encompass
according to the hill Democrats are
debating how broadly to make their
impeachment case against President Trump
with some lawmakers seeking to expand
the list of charges even as the House
Judiciary Committee members signal a
relatively narrow approach House
Democrats at the first Judiciary
Committee impeachment hearing on
Wednesday gave the clearest sign yet of
the scope of their likely articles by
unveiling posters featuring three
possible charges abuse of power and
bribery obstruction of Congress and
obstruction of justice I'm free keep it
simple scopes at Eric's wawel directly
before recommending the nuclear
annihilation of all gun owners in the
United States the charts provided a
clear signal of intent by the Judiciary
Committee as did council norm aizen's
pointed questions to a panel of
constitutional experts about whether
Trump had committed the impeachable
offenses three witnesses invited by
Democrats all answered affirmatively
we'll get to their testimony in just a
little while suffice it to say that the
300-page report brought forward by Adam
Schiff yesterday Adam Schiff who there
are serious questions about Adams ships
behavior in this whole debacle okay that
report does not substantiate the charges
to the extent necessary to support an
impeachment effort Democrats overreached
her politically strategically legally
what they should have done is they
should have moved forward on censure
they should have said pres
interrupted something bad needed
something wrong here and now we are
moving forward with a censure motion and
forced republicans between a rock and a
hard place in the sense that if they
don't vote for center then they look
like hypocrites because from was not in
fact clean as the driven snow on this
whole thing and second if they did
endorse the century then Trump gets very
angry and yells about them on Twitter
and they get primary bow would have been
the smart Democrat political move
instead they decided to go whole hog
impeachment inquiry we're gonna get rid
of this guy now listen it's going
nowhere in the Senate we all know it's
going nowhere in the Senate the
Democrats know it's going nowhere in the
Senate the reason they are rushing this
thing forward the reason that they are
pushing as hard as they can to do this
as quickly as possible is because they
know they do not have the goods Adam
Schiff basically admitted as much
yesterday he said listen we have to rush
this because every day Trump's in office
is another danger to the Republic yeah
sure
I mean you've literally been saying he's
a danger to the Republic since the day
he was elected you said it's a danger to
the Republic when he tweets things you
don't like he made a big fuss when he
tweeted a picture of himself as Rocky
Balboa like a week ago
spare me okay but Democrats have been
pushing this Ajay's the threats that are
public since the very beginning and so
we have to rush this we have to rush it
we can't even wait for all the facts
Adam Schiff actually said that yesterday
he said we can't wait for all the facts
we don't have to wait for all the facts
remember Democrats in the fact portion
of the inquiry in the Intelligence
Committee with Adam Schiff leading they
called precisely one witness who had
ever had a direct conversation with
Donald Trump one Gordon Sunland the
ambassador to the you and Gordon Sumlin
did not give them what they were looking
for he did not give them a window into
Trump's intent with regard to his
activities in Ukraine and these are all
intent crimes abuse of power and bribery
that's intent and suggesting that
obstruction of justice has taken place
is an absurdity on his face there is no
obstruction of Congress there is no
obstruction of justice the reason there
is no obstruction of Congress or
obstruction of justice is because every
subpoena issued by the Democrats has
been challenged in court normally the
way a subpoena works is that you are
subpoenaed and then if you don't want to
answer the subpoena you challenge it in
court you wait for the judge to rule on
it and then you have to listen to the
judge not a single one of these
subpoenas has been ruled on by a judge
and Democrats are claiming obstruction
of justice anyway
Congress does not have the untrammeled
power to simply issue a subpoena and
then everyone has to obey or Congress
impeaches them it's not how any of this
works
the Democrats don't have the goods but
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats had
already pre committed to impeachment
literally the day that you open an
impeachment inquiry so today Nancy
Pelosi announced we're moving forward
with these impeachment charges now
that's hilarious also because as you'll
recall just yesterday Adam she was
saying no we're still making up our
minds we're still making up our minds
it's all Kabuki theater from the moment
she said impeachment inquiry impeachment
was inevitable I've been saying that
since that day Nancy Pelosi comes
forward and she says that she that she
is going to call on her colleagues to
impeach the President of the United
States it's very dramatic she says we
will impeach the President of the United
States should the president's actions
have seriously violated the Constitution
he leaves us no choice but to act she
spoke for about six minutes she took no
questions but she did in fact come back
to the podium and start yelling at the
press there's one point where she
started yelling at the press and we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the difficulties of
running a business okay it is very
difficult to run a business it's
particularly difficult to run a business
when you are racking up heavy legal
costs when you rack up these massive
legal costs it can really hurt your
bottom line this is one of the reasons
you should be using LegalZoom I've been
using LegalZoom for legal resources
since way before their response er of
the program like going back 10 years I
was using Legal Zoom for things like
wills and trusts over the past 18 years
Legal Zoom has helped more than 2
million business owners get started but
every entrepreneur knows that getting
started is just the beginning of your
journey what happens along the way
determines your success
that's what legal zooms network of
independent attorneys and tax
professionals can help with no one were
to turn for advice on trademarks tax law
changes reviewing contracts puts you at
an advantage plus you'll save money by
avoiding hourly fees because Legal Zoom
isn't in fact some law firm don't get
distracted by legal hurdles and business
questions as the Year winds down go to
Legal Zoom calm today find out all the
different ways they can help your
business and don't forget to enter the
promo code been in the box at checkout
that's legalzoom.com
promo code ben LegalZoom where life
meets legal go check them out right now
save yourself money
don't put your business behind the
8-ball when it comes to legal costs go
check them out at legalzoom.com promo
code ban again that's legalzoom.com
promo code Ben so remember according to
the Democrats this entire shebang is
based on a desperate need a desperate
need to impeach Trump on constitutional
lines on constitutional basis it is not
about personal animus for the President
of the United
States it's not about that at all that's
what Pelosi said she said this is just
about the the crucial nature of
impeaching the president for high crimes
and misdemeanors this prompted President
Trump for his part to go on Twitter and
tell the Democrats to get this done fast
because he's coming after him he said
the do-nothing radical left Democrats
have just announced that they're going
to seek to impeach me over nothing they
already gave up on the ridiculous
smaller stuff so now they hang their
hats on to totally appropriate perfect
phone calls with the Ukrainian president
this will mean that the beyond important
and seldom used act of impeachment will
be used routinely to attack future
presidents that is not what our founders
had in mind the good thing is that the
Republicans have never been more United
we will win now he is correct that he's
not going to be removed from office not
on the basis of the slim read the
Democrats have proposed here they just
don't have the goods when he says it's a
perfect phone call I've been saying all
along it was not a perfect phone call it
was obvious it was not a perfect phone
call but the Democrats overreached and
that overreach is going to allow Trump
to survive all of this and survive
fairly easily
okay so Nancy Pelosi again she here's
what it sounded like when she announced
the impeachment effort let's go back to
that clip here's here is her original
announcement of the impeachment effort
yesterday the Judiciary Committee at the
dishy area committee the American people
heard testimony from leading American
constitutional scholars who illuminated
without a doubt that the president's
actions are profound violation of the
public trust the president's actions
have seriously violated the Constitution
today I am asking our Chairman to
proceed with articles of impeachment
I commend our committee chairs and our
members or their sombre approach to
actions which I wish the president had
not made necessary okay so basically
according to Nancy Pelosi it is these
lawyers who came forward who changed the
entire nature of the ballgame gets a
lawyer testimony in just one second
because it did not change the nature of
the ballgame it was basically a bunch of
lawyers who are Democrats who came
forward and said that Trump should be
impeached and then one lawyer who
apparently is also a Democrat who said
Trump should not be impeached that is
not dispositive sorry that's not how
this works
okay so Nancy Pelosi says that then she
has this very wild moment where she's
about to walk offstage and James Rosen
who's a reporter formerly for Fox News
he asks her whether
is all based on hatred for Trump because
that of course is what Republicans and
Trump have been a legend right is that
this is all about personal animus that
Democrats want Trump out this isn't
about anything that is legally based
that there is no actual crime that's
been committed here and Nancy Pelosi
turns around and starts berating him in
the most bizarre possible fashion if
this were a Republican the media would
be talking about how and hingeless says
if this were a Republican if Mitch
McConnell did this the media would be
talking about how McConnell hadn't lost
his cool
about how McConnell was going crazy as
it is the media are talking about Nancy
Pelosi's righteous indignation standing
up for the Constitution of the United
States but what she says here is
patently not here's Nancy Pelosi saying
no it's not about hatred of Trump also
as a Catholic as a Catholic I'm offended
you use the word hate in the same
sentence with me
okay really we're gonna go here now
seriously it's an attack on your
religion if you say that you a Democrat
hates the president like that you hate
the president that is an attack on your
Catholicism by the way and that the
convenient Catholic card is one of the
more irritating points about Nancy
Pelosi a woman who bats abortion on
demand the suggestion that men can
become women and same-sex marriage
sponsored by the federal government none
of which are positions of the Catholic
Church is a very convenient Catholic
when it comes to invoking her
Catholicism for purposes of outrage
here's Nancy Pelosi getting very angry
that anyone would suggest that this
impeachment effort is about personality
rather than actual crimes and
misdemeanors Nancy Pelosi came out right
a fat elephant
thought sorry
this is about the Constitution of the
United States and the facts that leads
to the president's violation of zones of
office and as a Catholic I resent your
using the word hate in a sentence that
addresses me how dare you as a Catholic
I'm gonna call the Pope over here and
the Pope is gonna tell you how mean you
are
the Pope we're gonna get Francis in here
and he's gonna tell you that you are not
allowed to use the word hate with me
Nancy Pelosi
a woman who believes that abortion
should be legal all the way until birth
on demand for any reason we got the Pope
right in here man right in here by the
way does that look like a person who
doesn't hate the president right they're
just gonna ask that does that seem like
a person who is who is very calmly and
solidly just pointing out the law that
she really is centered that the rest of
that clip is even wild the retin she
starts the clip and she starts waving
her hands around talking about how the
president is she thinks he's a coward on
gun control and a coward on climate
change and those are all political
questions but this right here this is a
matter of standing up for the
Constitution does anyone believe this
crap no one believes this the media are
orgasming over it of course the media
are just orgasmic over-the-moon over all
of it but does it really make a
difference to the american people i
would suggest a probably not probably
not we'll get to more of this in just
one second first let's talk about how
you can save time and money this holiday
season so we approach it's Christmas we
approach at Hanukkah it's time to send a
lot of packages in the mail
but it's gonna be a pain in the butt to
schlep all that stuff over to the post
office and why should you pay a price
that you don't have to pay when you
could just go to stamps.com stamps.com
brings all the great services of the US
Postal Service directly to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps calm
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
and in class of mail anywhere you want
to send it once your mail is ready just
hand it to your mail carrier or drop it
in a mailbox it is indeed that simple
with stamps calm you got 5 cents off
every first-class stamp at up to 40% off
Priority Mail
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
business has already used stamps calms
if you haven't tried it yet
what exactly are you waiting for don't
delay sign up right now life is too
short to spend all that time schlepping
the boxes all the way to the post off
just do it from home we use it here at
daily wear it saves time it saves us
money right now you get a special deal
no risk my promo code Shapiro get a
special offered includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts using our code you'll be
saving money and supporting the show so
head on over to stamps comm click on
that microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
comm enter Shapiro stamps comm never go
to the post-office again so as I say the
media are just over the moon about the
fact that Nancy Pelosi has officially
opened this thing yeah it's the time and
she's not about hate she's not about
personal animus for the president
doesn't matter that the Democrats still
have not come up with the exact rounds
of the impeachment by the way good
indicator that you don't actually know
anything beyond you want the president
out when people say do you want to
impeach the president you go yeah and
they say well what do you want it how
they go well we're figuring it out it
seems as though perhaps it might have
something to do with you wanting Trump
out not so much you having objections to
the president's behavior per se or at
least objections serious enough to
warrant impeachment and again that Nancy
Pelosi invoking her Catholicism to be
offended how dare you how dare you say
that I am doing something that out of
hate no I'm I'm a I'm Mother Teresa
except Mother Teresa wasn't for the
on-demand killing of unborn human beings
other than that exactly like Mother
Teresa
exactly so so obviously that is silly
stuff in she's hanging her head and so
are the Democrats today on the testimony
of lawyers lawyers it's pressure
especially lawyers who are from like Ivy
League schools whose they called three
count them three lawyers I know amazing
life-changing they called three lawyers
yesterday who are all Democrats to
testify about how Trump should go and
Nancy Pelosi is basing hurt her
announcement today on the fact that
after one day of like four hours of
hearing now the Democrats know until
then they were on the fence but then
they heard the compelling words of a
professor named Pamela Carlin and that
changed everything that changed
everything because she is a legal
authority on impeachment now if the
Democrats had any stones at all what
they would just say is listen we don't
have to have League
authority to do this don't have to call
lawyers it's a political process we
think Trump is unfit for the presidency
we're impeaching him and then we can all
have a referendum on that and then we
can all say okay is impeachment
worthwhile when we have an election a
year away because that's really what
this is about isn't it is that the
Democrats can make every case they're
making against Trump in an election I
mean we're coming up hard on an election
right now the Democrats are choosing
their candidate right now and yet the
Democrats are trying to push impeachment
so that means they have to go above and
beyond the simple political case but
they don't have anything above and
beyond the political case so instead
they call a bunch of lawyers to jabber
about it so they call one woman named
Pamela Carlin and the media are touting
her yesterday I mean just a law
professor said Trump should be impeached
probably she's very objective in her
approach probably she's a constitutional
expert with no serious political bias in
any direction or alternatively she is a
wild liberal who is so far to the left
that Barack Obama did not choose her for
the Supreme Court in part because she
was too radical in the too far to the
left but he considered it also she
worked in the Obama department of
justice also she clerked for Harry
Blackmun on the Supreme Court she also
has performed litigation in Supreme
Court issues at Stanford Law she has
performed litigation in the Supreme
Court on landmark gay rights cases
trying to claim that sexual orientation
is protected by a title 9 of the of the
Civil Rights Act which of course it is
not
hey she's but she's an expert she's an
expert she is widely known in liberal
circles according to the New York Times
she is chairman of the director of the
board of directors for the left-leaning
American Constitution Society in
December 2016 she and other scholars
signed a letter expressing concerns over
Trump's statements and actions during
the 2016 presidential campaign she
suggested in May 2017 that we had hit a
constitutional crisis here is a
flashback clip of Professor Carlin
suggesting that when she saw Trump's
name in public she physically had to
cross the street okay this is what the
Democrats called as their objective
witness on whether Trump ought to be
impeached I was struck eight you know I
came in from the airport yesterday and I
got off the bus from Dulles down at
unpleasant I walked up to the hotel and
as I was walking past what used to be
the old post office building and is now
that Trump Hotel which I had to cross
the street of course but never never you
see it's not about hatred for Trump guys
it's about pure constitutional
righteousness that's all it's not how
much he hates Trump by the way how
terrible is this is this person as a
witness she decided to be a great idea
to just go after barren like barren has
nothing to with anything but she in the
middle of her testimony bizarrely
decides to attack the president's son
for no reason at all just because she
wants to be a horse's ass
so here's Pamela Carlin being a horse's
ass and Trump has said Article two does
not have give him the power to do
anything he wants and I'll just give you
one example that shows you the
difference between him and a king which
is the Constitution says there can be no
titles of nobility so while the
president can name his son Baron he
can't make him a baron I mean that oh
the hilarity
oh I mean what don't worry she's not
partisan guys she's not partisan she
just drops Baron Trump jokes a mansion
by the way the Republicans had tried to
impeach obama which they did not and
imagine that they had gone up there made
sasha and malia jokes would the media
have ever ever stopped talking about how
mean-spirited that was later she had to
apologize for it later she case she said
you know probably I shouldn't have
referenced mare and that was in her
prepared testimony okay she had
pre-written that joke it wasn't like he
just occurred to her to make a pun about
barons name she's like oh well I can
make up I could like titles of nobility
his name is Baron first of all it's a
terrible joke did you know that there
was an artist in the United States named
Prince but he was not actually a prince
just want to put that out there did you
know that Martin Luther King was not
actually a king unbelievable things you
learn each and every day in this country
here is just here is Pamela Carlin
having to back off of this and then
apologize for referencing Baron then if
I can just say one thing I want to
apologize for what I said earlier
about the president's son it was wrong
of me to do that
I wish the president would apologize
obviously for the things that he's done
that's wrong but I do regret having said
that okay that's that's always my
favorite thing is I apologize for that
is this by the way the worst tactic you
can use in marriage honey I really
apologize for not taking out the garbage
but I wish you would apologize for being
terrible at everything that obviously a
great way to make an apology okay in
just a second we'll get to more of the
Democrat witnesses who apparently
convinced the Democrats higher echelon
that they must impeach we'll get to that
in just one second first I don't tell
you about a movie that is now out it is
great it is called no safe spaces no
safe spaces starting my friends Adam
Carolla and Dennis Prager it's in
theaters nationwide Friday December 6th
it takes you to the heart of the free
speech battle in America and Adam and
Dennis take on this it's a pretty great
I've seen the movie it's really terrific
not just because I'm one of the stars to
them with you although mostly because
I'm one of the stars in the movie but
also you should go see no safe spaces
because it is a wild hilarious well done
ride to show you the effects of
political correctness identity politics
and canceled culture no safe spaces
argues about why free speech is
important to a free society how it's
being threatened what we can do to fight
back by the way the film does take you
behind the scenes of that crazy 2017
Berkeley speech that cost the City of
Berkeley six hundred thousand dollars
for security because an Tifa decided to
threaten violence because I was speaking
about free speech they're a bunch of
different voices in this thing President
Obama shows up Brett Weinstein Cornel
West Jordan Peterson take all your
liberal friends to see it because it
really should cross partisan aisles go
check out no safe spaces this weekend is
rated pg-13 in theaters Friday December
6th also help out conservative
filmmaking I'd help out filmmaking that
makes a difference in the culture go to
no safe spaces calm slash Ben for ticket
information and theater locations go
check them out right now okay so as I
say the Democrats Pelosi launched the
statement this morning saying that it
was the legal testimony of these
objective experts that convinced her
that a constitutional crisis had arisen
and it was time for impeachment to be
invoked okay but as I point out here
Pamela Carlin is a hack she's always
been a hack
she is a hack who is a very far left
radical okay Matt Gaetz
congressman of Florida points out to
Carlin that she is routinely spoken
about her conservatives are nasty people
and she just
likes them now you you have you ever
been on a podcast called versus Trump I
think I was on a live panel that the
people who ran the podcast called versus
Trump on that do you remember saying the
following liberals tend to cluster more
conservatives especially very
conservative people tend to spread out
more perhaps because they don't even
want to be around themselves did you say
that yes I did oh she's a perfectly
objective witness and you can hear the
Democrats laughing about it uh no this
has nothing to do with partisanship guys
I believe Nancy Pelosi when she says
she's very offended as a Catholic than
anyone would think this is merely a
partisan inquiry now that I'm old enough
to remember cuz I'm more than six months
old when Nancy Pelosi suggested that
impeachment would be inappropriate if
she did not have bipartisan support
there's not one Republican that supports
impeachment not one that should tell you
something and it's not just that
President Trump has tremendous way
inside his own party not one even
Republicans in swing districts even
Republicans in swing states okay so she
is the most obvious far left legal
commentator called pamela Carlin but
she's not the only one called by the
Democrats another professor named Noah
Feldman he teaches at Harvard Law School
well Feldman also testified that
President Trump should be impeached and
there's only one problem with that which
is that Noah Feldman in the past as in
like in the last two years wrote a piece
in The New Yorker looking for grounds
for president Trump's impeachment and
has talked too openly as early as like
March 2017 about how Trump's tweets made
him impeachable and led to a
constitutional crisis but here's Noah
Feldman explaining why this set of
circumstances he's really in beatable
like truth not not the other stuff that
I said was impeachable before this stuff
is the truly impeachable stuff on the
basis of the testimony and the evidence
before the House President Trump has
committed impeachable high crimes and
misdemeanors by corruptly abusing the
office of the presidency specifically
President Trump has abused his office by
corruptly soliciting president
Vladimir's zelanski of Ukraine to
announce investigations of his political
rivals in order to gain personal
advantage including in the twenty
20 presidential election okay but he's
also very objective guys it's not that
he thinks Trump's been impeachable since
day one it's only now only now have
circumstances arisen and then the
Democrats call the third witness whoa
third witness we'll get to that third
witness in just a second another very
objective witness being called by the
Democrats to testify that impeachment is
appropriate here we'll get to that in
just one second first would you like
some free money I know it sounds crazy
but this is an actual program it will
save you money then they're not actually
gonna send you a check but effectively
speaking that's kind of what they are
doing because every time you shop online
honey
searches the web for all of the promo
codes that you need in order to save
money on every deal so you can make sure
that you are always getting the bet the
best deal honey has saved me probably
thousands of dollars at this point it
works on every shopping site from
Express to Amazon to anyplace I mean
honey is constantly trying to save you
money all you have to do is put on your
computer it runs in the background and
then every time you shop it searches for
the best deal for you it's a free
browser extension that automatically
finds the best promo codes whenever you
shop online honey has found it's over 10
million members over a billion dollars
in savings
honey supports over 20 thousand stores
online and they've got over a hundred
thousand five-star reviews on the google
chrome store again I've been using it
shopping for the holidays it's been
saving me a fortune if you're buying
gifts this holiday season you need honey
if you're not you probably know somebody
who is so do them a solid and tell them
about honey honey can help make sure
you're getting the best price for
whatever it is you're buying it is free
to use and installs in just two clicks
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash Ben that's join honey calm slash
pencil for free you're saving money
sounds great cuz it is go to join honey
calm / bed and get honey for free I can
testify it save me a bunch of money join
honey calm / Ben ok check that out so
the Democrats also called a third lawyer
oh boy you're okay if it seems as though
I am less than impressed with people who
have law degrees it's cuz I have one
okay because I went to the same Ivy
League schools as many of these
professors because they have the same
degree that I do and you know what it
does it teaches you to think in a
particular legal way but it does not
obscure your politics if you are a
Democrat and you went to Harvard Law
School
you're still a Democrat if you're a
Republican then you went to Harvard Law
School you are still a Republican Ted
Cruz went to Harvard Law School Barack
Obama went to Harvard Law School okay so
the law degree does not confer upon you
a degree of objectivity that suddenly
make
you magically capable of discerning
whether an offense is inherently
impeachable it's a very silly contention
that's exactly what Anson Pelosi is
contending today again if she had the
guts she'd just say listen I don't care
what the lawyers say this is impeachable
we're doing it we're doing it because
it's impeachable and i think it's
terrible but instead it's like no these
these legal authorities say we must is
with sadness in my heart and prayer for
the president that's always the most
obnoxious thing is when you hear Nancy
Pelosi say things like and I'm not I'm
not angry at the president I'm just
paying for him yeah I'm sure I'm sure
you get down on your knees every night
and you pray to God for President Trump
I am sure devout Catholic and Nancy
Pelosi is I'm sure that that's what she
does every night when she is being when
she's not being offended by people
saying the perhaps she hates the
president so the Democrats call forth
Michael Gerhart a professor who
according to the New York Times made
impeachment his specialty Gerhardt
testified that he's a professor at
University of North Carolina this is the
second time he's appeared as a witness
and he he was called in 1998 to testify
on Clinton's impeachment okay so Michael
Gerhardt said the Trump's actions are
worse than any other prior president any
of them any prior president like all of
them which is that a hell of a statement
I mean like Watergate is a thing that
happened we've had teapot dome we've had
the president of the United States FDR
essentially tried to pack the Supreme
Court of the United States and force
private citizens to display insignia in
their window so they would be left alone
by the government we've had Woodrow
Wilson run completely roughshod over the
Constitution of the United States and
merely arrest people he disagreed with
so yeah I mean we're talking about like
things that are bad that President FDR
in turned a hundred thousand Japanese
American citizens and the Supreme Court
by the way okayed that in Korematsu so
in any case the the idea that President
Trump has done something so far beyond
the bounds of any other sure okay sure
here is Gephardt professor Gephardt
saying a gore heart rather saying that
Trump's actions are worse than any other
prior president if Congress fails to
impeach here then the impeachment
process has lost all meaning and along
with that our Constitution's carefully
crafted safeguards against the
establishment of a king on American soil
and therefore
I stand with the Constitution and I
stand with the framers who were
committed to ensure that no one is above
the law well you know that that's very
exciting stuff except for the fact that
this particular dude Gerhardt it turns
out that he is also really far to the
left it turns out that he is a partisan
because he served as deputy media
director for former Vice President Al
Gore's for Senate campaign he was
involved in Bill Clinton's transition to
the White House in the early 1990s he
was involved in confirmation proceeding
for seven of the nine justices on the
Supreme Court and for two of those he
was special counsel to Senator Pat Leahy
Democrat of Vermont who is one of the
most left-leaning members of the Senate
so is that guy partisan yeah it turns
out he's a partisan too so on the basis
of three partisan Democrats the
Democrats are going hey look our
partisan Democrats say we should impeach
mmm we should impeach the Republicans
had one witness Jonathan Turley Jonathan
Turley is not Republican he's not I mean
as far as I'm aware there's no
information that suggests that he is a
Republican in fact he has been a liberal
contrarian for a very long time
according to the New York Times right he
he had called for Bill Clinton's
impeachment like 20 years ago but he was
also sharply critical of George W Bush
he represented in 2011 to lawmakers
representative Dennis Kucinich who's the
most left-leaning member of the of the
House of Representatives and
representative Walter Jones a Republican
who sued Barack Obama for participating
in the NATO air war over Libya without
congressional authorization so Turley is
not exactly kind of your classic he's
not exactly a classic Republican lawyer
and he testified yesterday too
and he said no you Democrats you have
not shown that this impeachment is a
political in fact you're proving
yourselves incredibly political here's
Turley if you prove a quid pro quo that
you you might have an appeal offense but
to go up only on a non criminal case
would be the first time in history so
why is that the case the reason is that
crimes have an established definition
and case law so there's a concrete
independent body of law that assures the
public that this is not just political
that this is a president who did
something they could not do
you can't say the president is above the
law if you then say the crimes you
accuse him of really don't have to be
established okay that's a great boy me
to the point that he is making is if
you're gonna say the president's is
above the law
you have to establish what the law is if
you cannot establish what the law is
then really you're not saying he's above
the law you're saying he's below the law
and that you can impeach him for
something that is not in fact a criminal
offense
we'll get some more of jonathan turley
testimony yesterday and we'll get to the
media's response to all of that because
even some members of the media who you
would typically expect to be fairly
pro-impeachment we're like yeah I'm not
so sure about this you can see the
Democratic members of the media shifting
away from even pretending that this
isn't political even as the Democrats
maintain like Pelosi
that this is absolutely apolitical even
as the Democrats claim that many
left-leaning commentators they're like
you know what let's just get rid of the
ruse we want him out it's that simple
we'll get to that in just one second
first let me tell you about the greatest
holiday gift the greatest holiday gift
you wanna make sure that somebody loves
the holiday gift this year a very simple
answer cookies really has there ever
been a human being who doesn't like
cookies maybe Hitler like like who
doesn't like cookies everyone loves
cookies okay and that is why you should
go check out mrs. Fields special deal
this year when Debbie field started mrs.
Fields Cookies 40 years ago she won over
cookie lovers everywhere with her gooey
chocolate chip cookies melt in your
mouth brownies and passion for sharing
the joy of baked goods I mean this is
good stuff brownies cookies everything
joyous in life nowadays you can have
cookies sent right what do you want them
without visiting a bakery with gourmet
gift tins and baskets filled with
fresh-baked cookies you know that your
order will arrive fresh and flavorful
ordering is easy they can ship your
cookies anywhere across the country if
you're ordering as a gift you can add a
personal custom message or a company
logo or a family photo and mrs. fields
offers with a 100% customer satisfaction
guarantee
you know why they can do that has
everyone is satisfied with cookies every
single human to sweeten the deal our
listeners get 20% off your amazing order
when you go to mrs. Fields calm and
enter promo code Shapiro that's 20% off
any gift at mrs. Fields Calm promote
coach Shapiro
that's mrs fields calm mrs. fields calm
promo code Shapiro your cookies are on
the way why would you not enjoy the
cookies go enjoy the cookies mrs. fields
calm
Shapiro's okay we'll get to more of the
Democrats impeachment Sharad in just one
second but first if you're not already a
subscriber you're missing out head on
over to daily wire comm / subscribe
perhaps you missed out on our special
deals last weekend good news you can
still become a subscriber you have to
pay a little bit more than you would
have last weekend but it ain't that much
more and it's awesome for as little as
10 bucks a month you get our articles
had free access to all of our live
broadcasts our full show library select
bonus content our exclusive daily wire
app which is pretty awesome if you
haven't checked it out yet if you choose
the new All Access plan you get all of
that plus the legendary leftist ears
tumblr and our brand-new ask me anything
style discussion feature that allows you
to engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis you also get
our Sunday special early on Saturday
this week Sunday special features my
good friend Lila Rose is the head of
live-action a pro-life advocate
extraordinaire
here's a little of what that sounds like
the head nurse at UCLA sits me down and
she says Point Blank
UCLA doesn't support women who are
pregnant or help them so it was very
crystal clear immediately why there's no
pregnant girls on campus because we were
being told point blank you should have
an abortion
[Music]
it's really interesting stuff really
important stuff if you are on the fence
about the pro-choice versus pro-life
debate it's worth listening to check
that out that's our Sunday special this
week we are the largest fastest growing
conserved a podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so the Republican Party brings forth
Jonathan Turley who again is not a
Republican to point out that the
Democrats have not actually fulfilled
any definition of a statutory crime he
says there was no bribery nor at store
no extortion no abuse of power shown and
of course Turley is exactly correct so
if I were to summarize your testimony no
bribery no extortion no obstruction of
justice no abuse of power is that fair
not on this record okay and then Turley
points to the Democrats and he said
listen if you want to talk about abuse
of power
you guys are abusing power and right now
what you guys are doing is an abuse of
power I can't emphasize this enough and
I'll say just one more time if you and
Peter president if you make a high crime
and misdemeanor out of going to the
courts it is an abuse of power
it's your abuse of power you are doing
precisely what you're criticizing the
president for doing we have a third
branch that deals with conflicts of the
other two branches and what comes out of
there and what you do with it is the
very definition of legitimacy okay what
what Turley is saying here specifically
is he's talking about the obstruction of
justice charge he said what I've been
saying which is of course legally
factual if someone subpoenas you you go
to a court if you don't want to obey the
subpoena the court then rules if you do
not abide by the court now you're
obstructing justice but it is not an
obstruction of justice to tell the
Democrats to stuff it until you go to a
court and if Democrats are to call that
obstruction of justice they're
pretending the judicial branch does not
exist now speaking of abuse of power The
Wall Street Journal editorial board has
an interesting editorial today about
Adam Schiff and his possible abuse of
power according to The Wall Street
Journal editorial board Adam shifts
300-page House Intelligence and
peach-pit report does not include much
knew about president Trump's Ukrainian
interventions but it does disclose
details of telephone calls between
ranking intelligence Republican Devin
Nunes Trump attorneys Rudy Giuliani and
Jay Sekulow
reporter John Solomon former Giuliani
associate left Parnas the White House
and others
the details are metadata about the
numbers in length of the calls not the
content the impeachment press is playing
this as if the calls are a new part of
the scandal but the real outrage here is
shift snooping on political opponents
the Democrats motive appears to be an
attempt to portray Devin Nunes a
presidential defender and ships leading
antagonist in Congress as part of a
conspiracy to commit impeachable
offenses shift told the
press on Tuesday I think it is deeply
concerning that at a time when the
President of the United States was using
the power of his office to dig up dirt
on a political rival that there may be
evidence that there were members of
Congress complicit in that activity The
Wall Street Journal editorial board says
complicit in what doing his job of
congressional oversight talking to
trumps where to get a complete view of
the Ukrainian tale
apparently Schiff now wants to impeach
members of Congress - this is an
unprecedented and it looks like an abuse
of government surveillance authority for
partisan gain Democrats were caught
using the steel dossier to coax the FBI
into snooping on the 2016 Trump campaign
now we have elected members of Congress
using secret subpoenas to obtain and
then release to the public the call
records of political opponents our
sources
says The Wall Street Journal say that
shift issued a subpoena in September to
AT&T demanding call logs for five
numbers including Giuliani's subsequent
subpoenas to AT&T and Verizon demanded
more details
Republicans were told of the subpoenas
but under rules of committee secrecy
they couldn't raise public objections
here the company's appears to have hands
it over metadata based on little more
than shifts say-so and an 18 T's case in
response to a request that was made even
before the house began a formal
impeachment inquiry 18 C released a
statement on Wednesday saying it is
required by law to provide information
to government and law enforcement
agencies but AT&T can question the
validity of subpoenas and courts and
they had grounds to do so given the
highly political nature of the requests
then again maybe it felt it had no
choice well Joyce will leave it to legal
experts to decide whether a powerful
congressman's demands of a highly
regulated company are extortion
according to The Wall Street Journal
shifts metadata disclosures hardly bear
on his impeachment case Giuliani had
broadcast to the world he wanted Ukraine
to investigate hunter and Joe Biden he's
also Trump's personal attorney the
Schiff have a legal opinion saying he
can ignore attorney-client privilege
shift published a select logs of
Giuliani's calls but presumably he has a
record of everyone
Giuliani spoke to for months imagine the
political outrage of Republicans had
snooped on Rudy Giuliani's attorneys
shifts accusations against Nunes are
even more suspect the Democrat doesn't
know the content of Newton's
conversations and the Republican says he
believes his spring talks with Giuliani
related to the Mullen report Nunes can
speak to whomever he likes Schiff has no
authority to investigate fellow members
since Schiff is gonna release the call
logs of Republicans can we see the logs
of his calls with the impeachment
president by the way with any
whistleblowers
and by the way shifts targets include
one of their own John Solomon how is
Solomon's reporting trout relevant to
impeachment the media usually condemn
government officials who use
surveillance to track and intimidate the
media but here they're cheering Schiff
on so you subpoenaed a TNC for a bunch
of phone numbers including Giuliani and
then just spilled that out into public
how exactly is that a good look it
meanwhile it seems like the Democrats
themselves many of the Democratic
commentators are basically just letting
the cat out of the bag at this point
they're not gonna bother with the whole
pretense of legality here they're just
gonna say no one cares about the actual
articles of impeachment whatever just
say he sucks and then impeach him
Michael Tomas Key has a piece of the New
York Times today called do voters even
care about the articles of impeachment
everyone knows what Trump did the
Democrats shouldn't draw out the process
any longer than necessary
in fact why even do the process that's
the real question why don't you both
from Pietschmann we all know what this
is we all know the Democrats are voting
this way this whole thing is ridiculous
it's not convincing a single American
one way or the other not one right all
this is baked into the cake in this way
to mask ease right because this is a
hack job but some ascii says the
question is now facing House Democrats
concern scope and speed whether to pass
one or two articles of impeachment
quickly or bide their time and pass
several articles that more
comprehensively reflect the record of
Trump's crimes against the Constitution
in general those in the former camp tend
to be members from purple swing
districts that mr. Trump may have
carried in 2016 they've almost all
signed on to the effort at this point
but they just as soon get it over with
and get back to talking about
prescription drugs those in the latter
camp tend to be from safer blue
districts which gives them the freedom
to take a position that sounds more
uncompromising by the way there should
be a dead giveaway that Democrats know
they're losing this debate if the purple
district Democrats are the ones pushing
for a rush you know this ain't going
well for the Democrats
if only blue district Democrats are like
yeah let's take our time and put this
together that means only the true
believers really think that there are
grounds for impeachment here the purple
Dems are going to vote with the blue
domes because they have to because of
partisanship but they don't actually
believe that they have the grounds to do
it and they don't actually believe that
they have the political wherewithal to
benefit from it
according to Michael Tomas key he says
it's easy to see why this has become
such a pitched battle it's a deeply
emotional question so many it's a clear
matter of right and wrong to fail to
condemn Trump's many sins and official
articles of
constitutes a whitewashing of history
but everyone knows what went on so let's
just push forward he says he says an
extended process might produce more
riveting testimony but if a court
separately orders the former White House
Counsel time against testified he will
have to whether it's officially part of
an impeachment proceeding or not
Americans will watch his testimony and
take it in there's risk in the
maximalist approach a process that drags
on for too long
might just result in more democratic
infighting at a time when the party
needs to be unified there's a decent
argument for throwing the hot potato to
Mitch McConnell and shaming him and the
Senate Republicans for themselves the
blanket exoneration of mr. Trump well
that's not how this is gonna go by the
way if this gets to the Senate hunter
Biden and Joe Biden will be called they
will and then they will be subpoenaed
and then if they refuse the subpoena
will go to court and then Republicans
can make the exact same case Democrats
are making that simply by appealing a
subpoena hunter and Joe Biden are
involved in obstruction of justice
that's exactly what Democrats are
claiming now and we're seeing again this
opinion you know repeat it across the
media that we don't need any grounds for
this impeachment right we should just
push it forward no matter what at least
that's honest at least that's honest so
that is where things stand by the way
the media continued to try and dig up
dirt on President Trump in the weirdest
possible ways there's an article in The
Washington Post today going to talk to
his housekeepers what did they find
about the housekeeper's these
housekeepers apparently at mar-a-lago
were illegal immigrants which we've
known for a long time is the Trump
employed illegal immigrants and because
he runs a very large firm and because a
lot of large firms employee illegal
immigrants and now his firm employs he
verify but the real core of this dumb
Washington Post piece is that Trump has
personal habits and those personal
habits are supposedly bizarre so the
Washington Post has this long piece
today about how the president liked his
Diet Coke in small glass bottles with a
plastic straw that no one could be seen
touching impeach impeach the Washington
Post as the undocumented workers were
often left to perform the most intimate
and personal work those who cooked and
served Trump knew he liked his
cheeseburgers well done Trump loved
tic-tacs but not an arbitrary amount he
wanted in his bedroom Perot at all times
to full containers of white tic-tacs and
one container that was half full
the same will apply to the Bronx colors
brand face makeup from Switzerland that
Trump slathered on two full containers
one half full even if it meant the
housekeeper's had to regularly bring new
shirts from the pro shop because of the
rust color stain on his collar a special
washing machine in the laundry room was
reserved for his wife Melania Trump
clothing Donald Trump liked Irish spring
bar soap in his shower in peach he does
not use body wash fire soap is not as
clean as body wash in peach also it
turns out according to the Washington
Post I know breaking news here that
Trump's housekeepers quickly learn not
to throw out his soap even if it had
worn down to the tiniest sliver Trump
decided when he wanted something
discarded when that happened with
clothes or newspapers he would toss them
on the floor brutal cruel impeach you
know this is really dumb but yeah well I
definitely trust our media to be
objective in their coverage meanwhile
speaking of objective media coverage I
have to say I am deeply enjoying the
media coverage of Kamala Harris's
political minds it really is amusing to
me one of the reasons that it is so
immensely amusing to me is because
common was Candis he was a complete fail
and she'd left to the top of the
standings then she completely collapsed
and now he going conventional wisdom is
that everybody in the United States is
racist because we didn't make him our
Harris presidents like Barack Obama
never existed now if you say well Barack
Obama that doesn't show that you're not
racist well then why are you using the
presidential race is a litmus test for
racism either to litmus test or it isn't
if it is Americans ain't racist if it
isn't then Kamala Harris dropping out is
not an indicator of American racism but
Cory Booker is continuing to try and
play this card it's pretty amazing and
Cory Booker is a desperate desperate man
pops on those angry eyes and the angry
eyes blinks in very deliberate fashion
to demonstrate that he's extremely angry
hey guys and then he sends out emails
like this he's been sending these I mean
he is like a jilted lover man he is
sending these emails once every six
hours it is incredible so here's the new
one from Cory Booker today as the
current December 2 bait lineup stands
not a single one of the candidates who
will appear on stage is a person of
color this is
shame then well I disagree Cory the 2020
Democratic field promised one of if not
the most diverse sets of candidates in
modern history that you wouldn't see
that from looking at the frontrunner our
party is better than this it's time we
show it I love love that Cory Booker is
now calling his own party racist that's
what that is Cory Booker is now
suggesting that his own party is
completely racist it's fantastic it's
really really good stuff because again I
guess that's the way you play this game
inside the Democratic Party and then
there's a piece from Milan yay price a
political scientist who specializes in
contemporary black politics public
opinion and political rhetoric at the
New York Times called why there won't be
a black woman running for president cuz
she was terrible that's why I also love
that we are ignoring the simple and
obvious fact of Michelle Obama jumped
into the race today she would win the
nomination by 40 points going away and
probably be the next president a black
woman so know it ain't about black women
it is about Kamala Harris specifically
but we are now gonna get a bevy of
articles where every it's amazing it's
amazing no matter what the antecedent is
of the if/then relationship in
democratic statements the then is always
America's racist if the sky is blue
Americans are racist if Kamala Harris is
out Americans are racist if Barack
Obama's elected president Americans are
racist it doesn't matter what is on the
if side of that arrow the only thing
that matters is what's on the then side
of that arrow of that logical arrow so
why there won't be a black woman running
for president when senator Kamala Harris
of California entered the race for the
presidential nomination in January many
believed should be hard to beat writes
dr. Melania Price telegenic highly
educated from a multi-ethnic background
she would have been an ideal candidate
in the pre Obama era we expected her to
create an all-american narrative that is
relatable to a wide cross-section of the
country after all that's how President
Obama ascended in 2004 but Miss Harris
failed to do that as we write eulogies
of this one's promising campaign which
ends it on Tuesday it is important we
talk about more than just personal
failings by Harris and her staff members
we need to talk also about what
campaigning looks like for black women
and what challenges and hurdles the
Harris campaign laid bare there are
biases and structural disadvantages that
can be found in school
the media and the public responded to
her candidacy I mean oh the bias oh the
subtle racism something something subtle
and she says well it's because when we
talk about electability we mean white
know when you talk about electability
you mean not a crazy person Kamala
Harris if you were not a crazy person
would be a very likely nominee right now
unfortunately for Kamala Harris she was
a crazy person who locked up half the
state of California that didn't that
didn't work particularly well
Melania price professor at you and at am
University in Texas says I'm still
trying to make sense of her candidacy
and its larger implications but I have
seen how uncertainty about black women
can be their undoing in all kinds of
leadership positions fact black women
who grow up in similar household
circumstances to white women outperform
them in terms of how many of them go to
college and in terms of baseline income
well Miss Harris may not have been me
black women to upend these biases in
2020 we can't let our notions of who is
electable causes to overlook black women
in the future and that's not the only
article like this today there's also an
article from Danielle tempo amore over
at NBC News called Kamala Harris's
failed presidential campaign is bad news
for Democrats even her critics you don't
have to be a supporter of Harris or even
like her very much to understand why her
dropping out now is bad news for the
Democratic Party
Harris's exit from what was once a
historically diverse pool of
presidential hopefuls signals how truly
difficult that fight the fight for all
people to be represented by their
elected officials and to be heard by
those in positions of power truly is
because when diverse candidates such as
Harris or New York senator Kirsten
Gillibrand drop out of a presidential
race even as a white male billionaire
such as Michael Bloomberg and Tom Steyer
entrant something is broken by the way I
love that adds of all patrick entered
he's a black dude totally overlooked
here
no one cares they'll love the fact there
are two women on the stage still Club a
char and and Warren that matter Tom Lee
Harris is an indicator of deep brutal of
Americanism it's pretty amusing so let
them fight in the in the famous words of
the of that Godzilla film let them fight
okay time for a quick thing I like and
then anything that I hate so the
that I like it today so I'm late on this
I'll acknowledge because frankly look
like it so proper to me but my wife was
interested in watching the show we
watched the first episode and it's
really enjoyable this is us a network
television show it's available on Hulu
now I don't even know what Network it is
because I cut the cable a while ago but
this is us is actually the first episode
of it anyway is pretty spectacular and
extraordinarily pro-life it's one of the
great ironies of Hollywood that on an
emotional level they understand that a
baby is a baby as a baby it's on NBC I
guess that a baby is a baby is a baby
but on an intellectual level they refuse
to acknowledge this so the entire
premise of the opening episode of this
is us is that losing a baby during
childbirth is a horrific tragedy because
you've lost a baby not a cluster of
cells and yet the Democrats will still
claim that aborting a baby just before
birth is perfectly morally acceptable in
fact morally praiseworthy in many
circumstances here's the trailer for
this is us a extremely pro-life first
episode at least tell me to lose the
damn weight we lost the third baby but
you have two healthy children jack
I quit
so it's a little it's a little soap
opera but it's good and then some of the
performances are actually quite
spectacular so if you haven't checked
out this is us I can only go out for the
first episode so far so good it's really
good and really shockingly pro-life and
I won't tell you the twist at the end of
the first episode if you're one of the
five people like I was until five
seconds ago who doesn't know the twist
okay other things that I like today
there's a great article in The
Washington Post today about a guy named
Freddie figures who was set down next to
a dumpster in a rural area of Flora's
Panhandle in 1989 he is now an
entrepreneur worth millions of dollars
because it turns out that every human
life is worthwhile every single one a
passerby found him alone and in distress
and called police
the infant was hospitalized with minor
injuries for two days then placed in a
foster home
the couple who took him in at Nathan and
Betty figures lived in nearby Quincy
Florida they already had a daughter
daughter
shortly after Freddie began living with
them the figures is who often took in
foster kids decided to adopt him
he was called dumpster baby by other
kids at school cuz kids can be awful to
each other but as he grew older it turns
out that he was great with technology
he'd gotten so good at tinkering with
computers that when he was 13 the city
of Quincy hired him to help repair its
computers when he was fifteen he started
his first company figures computers
repairing computers in his parents
living room helping clients store their
data on servers he created he decided to
skip college and then his big break came
several years later in 2012 when at age
23 he sold a GPS tracker program to an
undisclosed company in Kansas for 2.2
million dollars he apparently created a
device also that he that he couldn't
certain his dad's shoe his dad
apparently developed Alzheimer's and
would wander off
he developed a device he could insert an
issue that would allow him to track him
plus talk to him through his shoe Nathan
figures the father died in 2014 shortly
after Freddy started figures
communications and developed a tee
custom software programs with the money
he'd earned from his smart shoe
technology he now lives in parkland
Florida he's found as a founder of
figures Wireless a privately held
telecommuting telecommunications company
he said was appraised in 2017 at worth
more than 62 million dollars and also
runs the figures Foundation which
donates to a variety of causes including
relief efforts after natural
disasters college scholarships for high
school students and assistance with
school supplies for cash-strapped
teachers spectacular spectacular story
after figures grew up he learned that
his birth mother was a prostitute with a
drug addiction he said he has not met
her he said he has no desire to he said
my parents adopted me and gave me love
and a future they did their best to make
the world a better place and now that's
all I want to do - he's married to
Natalie figures an attorney and he is
raising his first child Rose who is two
years old yes you know it's a good thing
that that kid was born good thing for
the world good thing for for the United
States good thing for his family the the
idea that circumstances are better when
you kill an unborn human being because
the unborn human being is gonna be born
into a bad situation bad situations can
be made better death cannot so I'd say
that's a great story
okay we've run out of time so we'll skip
things I hate today but we will be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content or we'll see you here
tomorrow for our Friday frenzy this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jessa alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 democratic representative Jerry
Nadler and the House Judiciary Committee
presided over the first day of official
impeachment hearings yesterday were
expert witnesses made the incisive
constitutional argument that orange man
bad orange man very very bad explained
to the expert constitutional experts
therefore we got to overturn the 2016
election we will examine their arguments
and the arguments against impeachment
from an unexpected source check it out
on the Michael Moore Show
[Music]